es geht um fast 1800 schriftrollen aus
dem antiken herculaneum das ist eine
antike stadt am golf von neapel die
genauso wie pompeji bei dem verheerenden
ausbruch des vesuvs im jahr 79
untergegangen ist die bibliothek und
damit auch die besagten schriftrollen
wurde dabei fast bis zur unkenntlichkeit
verkohlt mit hilfe eines
teilchenbeschleunigers könnten sogar
kostbare funde wieder lesbar gemacht
werden bei denen die bisherigen
techniken versagt haben krieg zum
science fiction hier gibt es spannendes
seines videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
eigentlich sind sie unlesbar doch
forschungsteams tüfteln schon lange zeit
daran die sogenannten herculaneum
schriftrollen zu entziffern
diese waren beim ausbruch des vesuvs im
jahr 79 nach christus mit verschüttet
worden
damals wurde nicht nur die stadt pompeji
sondern auch die stadt herculaneum unter
ascheschicht bedeckt die zum teil
meterhoch waren die komplette bibliothek
der stadt fiel dem verheerenden
vulkanausbruch zum opfer sie enthielt
hunderte papierdokumente die dadurch
nicht nur bis zur unkenntlichkeit
verkohlt sondern auch noch zusammen
gepresst wurden und damit letztlich auch
konserviert worden
im 18 jahrhundert konnten archäologie
teams immer in einigen der schriftrollen
bergen doch bis heute lassen sie sich
nicht einfach entrollen ohne dabei zu
zerfallen die konservierung ist damit
leider nur schwer zu nutzen teile der
schriftzeichen jetzt immer noch
existieren verschwinden beim versuch sie
zu lesen vertrag sehr zum bedauern der
fachleute dazu wie dem keller von der
universität neapel diese reiche sammlung
die vorwiegend philosophische texte der
epicor enthält ist ein einzigartiger
kulturschatz die bibliothek von hercules
enthält also wichtige und einzigartige
abhandlung griechische philosophen
seitdem gab es einige experimente das
unlesbare wieder lesbar zu machen
bei den ersten versuchen wurden die
schriftrollen aber immer entrollt und
auf feste unterlagen befestigt um so den
papyrus zu stabilisieren und das hat
jedoch zur folge dass die vorderseite
zwar in ziffer ist der inhalt der
rückseite aber für immer verloren ist
doch nicht selten ist eben auch die
rückseite der rollen mit text
beschriftet erfolgreich waren fachleute
unter anderem mit verschiedenen röntgen
knicken und multi spektral aufnahmen so
konnten kleinere verblasste
textabschnitte und einzelne worte
entziffert werden
doch die rückseite bleibt weiterhin ein
großes rätsel dazu der italienische
wissenschaftler graziano ranocchia die
herausforderung liegt heute darin den
text auf der rückseite durch
nichtinvasive bildgebung methoden lesbar
zu machen ohne dass man die fragmente
von ihrer schützenden unterlage entfernt
genau dazu vermeldet ein italienisches
forschungsteam jetzt einen erfolg die
fachleute nutzen eine spezielle
aufnahmetechnik mit der die verführung
fragmente bestrahlt wurden konkret
handelte sich um licht der wellenlänge
bis zu 2500 nanometer das besondere
hierbei dieses licht konnte selbst die
dünnen papier umschichten durchdringen
da die strahlung langweiliger ist als
das sichtbare licht die so entstandenen
aufnahmen wurden dann mit einer
speziellen software nachbearbeitet der
ganze aufwand hat sich gelohnt denn
somit konnte das italienische
forschungsteam tatsächlich den text der
rückseite analysiert dazu schreiben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
in ihrer studie
wir konnten an verschiedenen stellen des
papieres gruppen von buchstaben und
wörtern lesen die zweifelsfrei von der
rückseite der rolle stammen die
forschenden konnten so nicht nur einen
bereits transkribierten text korrigieren
sie spürten zudem auch noch bislang
unentdeckte textpassagen auf und das
nicht nur auf der rück sondern sogar
auch auf der vorderseite hier konnten
bislang unsichtbare randnotizen
entziffert werden die so analysierte
text rolle ist demnach teil eines
lehrbuches von dem antiken philosophen
viele demos das forschungsteam ist
optimistisch dass in der nahen zukunft
weitere eigentlich unlesbare texte
lesbar gemacht werden könnten
sie schreiben in ihrem fazit diese
ermutigenden ergebnisse lassen eine
zukünftige untersuchung der gesamten
herculaneum sammlung und anderer papiere
mit dieser methode sowohl möglich als
auch wünschenswert erscheinen zeitgleich
arbeitet auch ein us forschungsteam an
dieser spannenden aufgabe doch ihr
verfahren unterscheidet sich von dem
ihrer italienischen kolleginnen und
kollegen
denn diese fachleute konzentrieren sich
auf das entziffern dennoch
zusammengerollten schriftstücke dazu
wird ein teilchenbeschleuniger genutzt
mit dem wir rollen im ganzen
durchleuchtet werden
so werden diese quasi virtuell entrollt
das große problem die antiken texte sind
mit einer tinte verfasst worden
die aufrufs basiert schriftrollen die
dagegen mit metallhaltigen pigmenten
beschriftet wurden lassen sich viel
leichter entschlüsseln beispielsweise
mit röntgenstrahlung die
dreidimensionale verteilung der pigmente
in der rolle kann dann mit digitalen
techniken zu einem text zusammengesetzt
werden doch die antike schrift lässt das
nicht zu deswegen setzt das os
forschungsteam auf die extrem helle
synchrotronstrahlung des
teilchenbeschleunigers des diamond light
source in oxfordshire
so soll das innenleben der rollen
kartiert werden doch wie genau das
funktionieren soll das ist noch nicht
klar die forscherinnen und forscher
hoffen darauf dass durch diese technik
unterschiede zum vorschein kommen die
auf der dichte der tinte basieren
skeptiker bezweifeln das konzept
allerdings doch der vergleich mit
fragmenten die bereits vor einigen
jahrhunderten entrollt wurden könnte zur
identifikation der erhofften tinten
merkmale führen eine eigens dafür
entwickelte maschinen lernsoftware
könnte dann schließlich den text aus
diesen daten filter gab es vor uns
bereits eine zivilisation eine mega
spannende frage anklicken anschauen und
unbedingt neugier zum abonnieren erst
vor knapp einem jahr gestartet und jetzt
schon fast 30.000 boßhammer also
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran